JENNY BROWN: Welcome to Cloud
Security Basics, a series where
we explain the ins and outs
of securing your application
on Google Cloud.
Sound fun?
Then stick around,
because in this episode
you'll learn good practices
for securing your application
with Cloud IAM.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[SIRENS]
[STATIC]
[DIAL UP MODEM SOUND]
BRAD ACTOR: It's been a
while, Cloud Detective.
I see you understand the
flexibility and capabilities
of the cloud.
As you know, it makes it easier
to work faster and collaborate
more effectively.
But it also introduces new
responsibilities and security
risks.
And sometimes, those threats
are not on the outside.
Accounts can get hacked,
credentials leaked,
and employees disgruntled.
Whether accidental or
willful, internal users
represent the biggest threat
to your organization's cloud
security.
For your sake, Detective, I hope
you can keep the wrong people
from accessing the wrong
resources at the wrong time.
JENNY BROWN: OK,
here's what we know.
Companies need to make sure
that only the right people can
access only the right resources
at only the right time.
One way to keep bad
actors out would
be to cut access for everyone
and have a few trusted people
dole out access manually.
But keeping productivity
high and getting the most out
of your cloud platform depends
on employees having access
to the resources and assets
they need with the least
amount of friction or delay.
And while just manually
allowing access every time
a person or application
needs resources
might work for a very, very
small organization, that
would quickly grow
unwieldy as the teams grow
or begin to work remotely.
So in order for our organization
to grow and function,
we need a better way
to manage access.
Luckily, Google Cloud provides
a lot of tools and services
to protect its users.
And this seems like a good time
to use Google Cloud's Identity
and Access Management, actually.
So IAM is Google
Cloud's unified system
for managing resource access,
assigning user permissions,
and controlling cloud
application service use.
It unifies all
access and control
and centralizes
it into one place.
Resources are the fundamental,
lowest-level components
that make up all
Google Cloud Services.
So some examples would
include Compute Engine VMs,
Pub/Sub topics, Cloud Storage
buckets, and App Engine
instances.
Cloud IAM lets organizations
keep track of everything
going on in their
Google Cloud environment
and prevent unauthorized
resource access.
Let's research more
to know how I can
use this to stop those threats.
Cloud IAM's access
management system
breaks down into
a few basic parts.
There's members, resources,
permissions, roles, policies,
and groups.
Members, or identities, can be
a Google account for end users,
a service account used to manage
apps and virtual machines,
a Google Group, or a Google
Workspace Cloud Identity domain
able to access a resource.
The member's identity is usually
the associated email address,
service account, or
group or domain name.
Resources, these are the
fundamental components
that make up all Google
Cloud services like VMs,
storage buckets, and more.
The organizations, folders, and
projects used to organize them
are also considered resources.
And permissions, which
are very fine-grained
access control on a
particular resource.
Roles.
A role is a collection
of permissions,
and permissions
determine what operations
are allowed on a resource.
When you grant a
role to a member,
you grant them all the
permissions the role contains.
Google Cloud has
predefined, built-in roles,
and you can also
create custom roles.
Policies, which bind a set of
Cloud IAM members to a role.
And if you want to define
who has what type of access
on a resource, you
create a policy
and attach it to that resource.
The policy also has other
information, such as auditing
configuration, but
we're going to focus
on identity aspects for now.
And groups.
Groups are used to help
you manage users at scale.
Each member of a Google
Group inherits the identity
and access management roles
that you granted to that group.
And this means that you can
use a group's membership
to manage users' roles
instead of granting
IAM roles to individual users.
Hmm.
So how should I use IAM
to protect my organization
from inside threats?
I could start by using
groups from the beginning.
This way, the security
admin wouldn't
have to manually
change permissions
as employees get
hired, fired, or move
throughout the organization
because the right policies
would be assigned to anyone I
move into the correct group.
This would also
make it a lot easier
to minimize mistakes, because
instead of assigning roles
and permissions to
a specific employee,
we could assign them to
groups and then add employees
to the correct groups.
This works even if
you already have
an organizational hierarchy
and groups in an existing
system like Active Directory.
And in that case,
you can continuously
sync that configuration
to Cloud IAM,
providing a single source of
truth for group membership
and reducing the
chance of a mistake.
And once we have
groups, we could also
make sure to name the
groups descriptively
so that it's obvious to tell at
a glance what each of the roles
has access to.
And this should
significantly reduce
mistakes that come from
assigning the wrong roles
to the wrong groups.
A good strategy here would
be to make a nested folder
hierarchy apparent with naming.
One general rule would be to
begin with the organization
name and then expand out the
folder tree with the project
name.
That's it.
I can use these components to
shore up my system's defenses.
Let's see what Brad
Actor thinks about that.
[STATIC]
BRAD ACTOR: Argh.
Detective, it seems like
you've foiled my attempt again.
Somehow, you figured out
that properly using Cloud IAM
greatly reduces the risk
of security violations.
I'm surprised you even
picked up on using groups
to simplify the process
of managing access
rights for employees that
move around your organization.
But what about the access you've
given to non-human entities
like applications that need to
access your secure resources
to function?
Have you secured those?
For your sake, I hope you
have, because next time,
I'm not focusing
on your employees,
but instead on your
scripts and applications.
JENNY BROWN: So there you
have it, another episode
of Cloud Security Basics.
Next episode, we'll focus
on using service accounts
to protect automated access
to your cloud resources.
So stay tuned for the rest
of the Cloud Security Basics
series, because when
it comes to security,
you can't let bad actors win.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[SIRENS]